I need to show you something
no come on yep here we are
this this I posted this video about
North Korea and this didn't make it in
because it needs to be explained a
little bit more a page from The New York
Times December 28 1945. the news that is
unfolding as the war is ending the
global war that almost tore apart the
entire world and it has a map just
watching the news unfold the big powers
are all meeting because Japan just fell
so what do we do with all these places
and then they go like a little explainer
they talk about what they're going to do
with Japan with Korea they're gonna
split it between the Soviets and the
Americans and it's just gonna be for a
few years it's not that big of a deal
okay let's move on no that's not what
happened the division of the Korean
Peninsula why we have North Korea today
I go way deeper into this history in the
video but I think the reason I love this
piece of paper is we're reading
newspapers like this right now
speculating how it's all going to end up
and decades from now they'll look back
at those newspapers and be like yikes
you guys have no idea what was coming
not to freak you out sorry